hello and welcome to the show everybody
thanks for watching thanks for being
here remember if you're if you're
watching on Facebook and you want to get
the entire show all you have to do is
subscribe on iTunes or you can head over
to YouTube or you can become a premium
subscriber on The Daily wire where you
get a lot of other benefits including
including full access to my show which
is kind of like you know not the best
thing but but you do get that as well so
as we as we covered extensively
yesterday the left and the media utterly
embarrassed itself with this Covington
Catholic story they got played by Nathan
Phillips who is a a liar and a fraud
tried to provoke an altercation with
these students and when he failed he
decided to run to the media and lie
about them which he is still continuing
to do by the way he hasn't let off and
and we're gonna we're gonna get to that
in a minute now they also the left and
the media they believed and promoted a
version of the story that entirely
excluded the role that was played by the
black Hebrew Israelites which are these
crazy cultists who kicked everything off
by verbally assaulting the boys and also
random passers-by and Native Americans
they were just insulting everyone with
racist bigoted anti-gay slurs but the
left in the media just just left them
out of the story didn't didn't even
mention that they were there and even
now as members of this school as
students at the school kids you know 14
15 year old kids are their faces and
their names are being plastered
everywhere their their biographies are
being analyzed by the media some of them
are now household names and and even
then even now the names of the black men
who actually are guilty of harassment
and abuse and are the ones who started
all of this their names are unknown they
remain anonymous does anyone know who
they're what what their names are does
anyone know anything about those guys no
because we're focusing all on on these
students who did nothing wrong all in
all the left in the media obviously
botched the story but now the facts have
come out right and we talked about this
yesterday we got into what all the facts
are the facts of
come out the boys have been completely
conclusively vindicated we now have
video evidence that shows exactly what
happened and it does not line up with
the story as it was first prevent
presented the real cult we know who the
real culprits are now the culprits are
the black Hebrew Israelites and also
Nathan Philips those those are the those
are the bad guys in this situation but
still even in spite of that the left is
clinging to its original narrative in
the face of all the evidence to the
contrary in the face of the fact that
they were clearly played by a con artist
they still are clinging to it they are
they're gonna stick with their original
version and now it's a game of just
trying to kind of retro actively justify
their treatment of these boys so what
have they come up with as they've
realized that the original story well
that's not how it went so now they're
trying to they're trying to come up with
with other reasons to go after these
kids and they've they've come up with a
few reasons but here's the big one that
was that you would have you would have
seen all over social media yesterday now
they're telling us that the Covington
Catholic students once wore blackface to
a basketball game where they proceeded
to harass the black players of the other
team now once again like we talked about
yesterday this accusation there should
be just sort of an immediate smell test
you can do with this sort of stuff and
when you hear a story like that that
they all wore black face to a basketball
game you should just you should
basically disregard it immediately
unless someone can provide you with
conclusive evidence that that is exactly
what happened
conclusive evidence in context and you
look at the whole thing and you say okay
will that happen but in lieu of that I
mean your your first reaction should be
okay no there's there's no way that
happened you're telling me all these
kids went to a basketball game in
blackface you you should be able to do
that the idea that a bunch of students
wouldwould just randomly we're racist
costumes to a basketball game and then
the school would take pictures of it now
the picture which I'll show you in a
minute of these kids allegedly wearing
blackface this is a picture taken by the
school so what the school all got does
it hey everybody where are your racist
costumes today we're gonna take pictures
put it online well that's just not
believable at all it seems like
something that's totally made-up and it
is yet the left has been spreading this
false story and now some some news
outlets have reported it so here's the
the trash worthless garbage rag New York
Daily News
here's their headline Covington Catholic
High School students in blackface at
past basketball game so they're just
putting it out there as a fact they're
not even thrown in an allegedly or some
have reported or whatever this is just
they're saying it's black face at a
basketball game this is this is just
libel this is they're defaming these
getting these kids this is a a false
story a story that they know is false
and I can only hope that New York Daily
News is is sued and run into into
bankruptcy and I can tell you that the
world would be better off without me the
New York Daily News has never
contributed anything of value to the
world or to journalism or anything but
here's what they have to say they say
I'll read a little bit from this news
article it says this won't help Kentucky
student not nick-san mins case a photo
said to be featuring Covington Catholic
High School students clad in black face
during a 2015 basketball game made the
rounds on Twitter Monday morning I'm in
last week's indigenous peoples marked
controversy the photo depicts several
white students some in blackface
shouting a tap on an opposing black
player while the photos origins couldn't
be verified the official Covington
Catholic High School YouTube account
published a video last January boasting
its basketball school spirit and several
clips including one from 2012 showcase
attendees chanting in blackface a
mockery of the opposing
yes so not only are they claiming that
the students were in blackface but
they're claiming in this news article
that they are wearing blackface to mock
the opposing player so they're they've
come up even with a with a motivation
behind this act which they've been
inserted as fact into their article
again I mean New York Daily News needs
to be sued into oblivion this is just
this is defamatory this is simply false
so what what is this all about well
first of all let's look at here's here's
here's the picture in question take a
look at it right now so there it is
so you notice how you notice how
everybody is in black right everyone's
wearing black and then some are wearing
black paint others are in all black
clothing so what was the point of that
was it was it a where you're racist
costume to the basketball day at
Covington Catholic um
which which the school then videoed and
put online proudly for everyone to see
okay guys look at our racist event come
take a look at this this is great look
at our racism folks look at this is that
what happened now I don't doubt that
leftist would actually believe that a
Catholic school would do something like
that that there would be a Catholic
school conspiring in a mass act of
random racism but anyone with say a
third of a functioning brain would would
know that that is completely ridiculous
and knows that there must be more to the
story and there is so this is what's
known as a blackout game okay
many schools do this it's very common it
happens all across the country everybody
wears black that's what a blackout game
is that's all it is every everyone is
just in the same color and then if you
get the if you get the bird's-eye view
of the stadium or if you see everyone
sitting in the bleachers it looks kind
of cool that everyone is in is in the
same color everyone's in black they also
have white out games they have games
where everyone wears blue okay so so
that that's it that's all story and if
everyone wearing black is black face
that I guess when they all wear white
for a white out game it's white face if
they all wear blue it's blue face in
other words to call it black face is a
lie it is a libelous lie why are they
screaming at the black player well
because it's a basketball game you
drooling dimwits it's a basketball game
that's what the home fans do at a game
they yell and they taunt the opposing
players not because they're black but
because they're the opposing player this
is what the fans of the home team have
done in every basketball and football
and hockey game that has ever been
played anywhere on earth in history this
is just what they do so all these people
are looking at this picture said oh my
gosh look at them yelling at that player
this is this I saw someone on Twitter
said it was I forget the phrase he used
he said it was something like looking
into the heart of evil or some phrase
like that I've this is someone who
apparently has never left their house
never turned on a TV never seen any sort
of sporting event that they would see
look at they're raising there they
appear to be taunting that player in a
different color jersey so this I don't
know well I never
you notice how leftist become these sort
of fainting victorian-era
you know damsels in distress so easily
it I mean usually these are the these
are the people who have no problem with
you know vulgarity they have no problem
with I mean they're the ones accusing
everyone else of being Puritans but then
they see something like this and they go
home my gosh I can't believe it it's
it's just it's called it's a it's a
sport ok these are these are these are
kids these are high school kids at a
sport getting rowdy that's what they do
you lying lying frauds you I mean this
whole thing makes me so angry because
the
pies are just so blatant and and they
know what they're doing these people
know what they're doing this is not that
they aren't they aren't stupid okay they
aren't so stupid that they don't
understand the concept of a high school
basketball game and what goes on it
there they aren't so dumb that they
don't understand the the idea that
sometimes everyone wears the same color
to a basketball game no they are I know
I call them drooling dimwits but
actually I'm doing them a huge favor
with that I mean that is a huge
compliment because either they are
drooling dimwits or they are despicable
evil people who are lying about these
kids and trying to get them at a minimum
expelled if not killed because these
kids are getting death threats there are
bomb threats going to the school and now
you're jumping in with this lie as well
so either you are a total [ __ ] or you
are evil and you are trying to get these
kids hurt with a lie those are the only
two options there are no other options
here at this point
exactly what they're doing in the words
of Marco Rubio let's dispel with the
fiction that they don't know what
they're doing they know exactly what
they're doing by the way speaking of bad
people Nathan Phillips has according to
the Cincinnati Enquirer has turned down
an offer to sit down and meet with the
students there's a local restaurant that
it offered to have a kind of break
breaking bread session between the two
sides and Nathan Phillips said that well
now's not the right time for that he's
not going to but in the same interview
he did insinuate that now he would be
possibly in favor of the kids getting
expelled he said he said you know
originally I wasn't paraphrasing but he
said originally I wasn't I wasn't in
favor of them getting expelled but now I
have to revisit that and of course he
does want various staff to be fired so
he wants the kids to be expelled he
wants the staff to be fired and this is
the hero that the left has given us this
Nathan Phillips character who again is a
liar a fraud and a bully who is picking
on these kids one other point to make
here the left now I want you to remember
something here so we had this incident
on Saturday but think back to what
happened last week and how the left
spent much of last week attacking Karen
pence because she got a job at a
Christian school then by the end of the
week he exposed Christian schools was a
hashtag trending on Twitter guess the
other attacking Karen pence for the
Christian school and then hashtag
exposed Christian schools and this was
just a hashtag war a bunch of people
were complaining about Christian schools
and then on Saturday a false narrative
was quickly constructed claiming that a
group of students from a Catholic school
harassed and taunted a Native American
man now I don't think that all of these
events came together coincidentally it's
very interesting that
exposed Christian schools that was the
hashtag trending on Friday and then the
thing happens on Saturday so if you go
when you check that hashtag now you're
gonna see a whole bunch of tweets about
Covington because the hashtag fits in
really nicely with this story except the
hashtag came along before the story we
have as I wrote last week we have
officially entered a new phase of the
culture war and gone officially are the
days when leftist pretend to see
religion as this sort of thing that
should be relegated to homes and
churches and private schools that was a
very small amount of extremely limited
and and qualified tolerance that they
had and that is now gone they will not
tolerate Christianity in any form in any
forum especially a private school so if
you go and you look at that hashtag that
I was talking about it is filled with
open unapologetic hatred for Christians
schools as an institution for the very
idea of Christian schools this is the
pattern with the left this is sort of
the trajectory I should say but the
pattern is very interesting you know
they maybe you've noticed this but they
tend to find these perfectly timed
real-world examples to demonstrate
whatever point they were already making
have you noticed that so think about in
the wake of Donald Trump's election they
they were wringing their hands and
saying that this is going to embolden
racists and bigots and there's gonna be
hate crimes and everything and just like
that reports of hate crimes come pouring
in and so for the first few months after
Donald Trump's election years you were
hearing about these hate crime reports
all the time now of course many of those
hate crimes proved to be hoaxes but
that's a minor detail as far as the Left
concerned and then think about Ferguson
you know Ferguson happened and we were
told that white supremacists police
officers are on the prowl you know
hunting down innocent black men and just
like that high-profile cases of police
brutality presented themselves and it
was just this rash
of of of cases like this and there were
riots across the country and all these
difference it was one city after another
one incident after another
now again many of those cases were not
legitimate examples of police brutality
but the truth or falsehood of the case
is irrelevant to leftist obviously and
then this week we were told that
Christian schools are nests of bigotry
and intolerance and then what hidden ho
video surfaces of kids at a Christian
school verbally assaulting a Native
American man I mean they couldn't have
scripted it any better could they now
I'm not suggesting that this is all part
of some sort of coordinated master plan
I don't think that these incidents are
all engineered by some shadowy devious
figure behind the scenes or sitting
behind a big oak desk stroking his white
cat you know and plotting all of these
various scenarios the the conspiracy if
we can call it that is much less
cinematic in scope and much less
dramatic and involves very little actual
conspiring because the media is already
on the same page there is no need for
them to have a meeting and get together
and say hey you know we've been talking
about this now let's go find an example
they don't need to say that out loud
it's just kind of understood that that's
what they're gonna do they decide what
sort of events what sort of incidents
will be reported and then which elements
of those incidents and events will be
highlighted so then something like the
Covington Catholic story is seized upon
and Exploited and retroactively Lee kind
of molded to fit with the narrative that
they'd already established that's that's
the way this works
now if
the media and the left had not already
been hammering on this point about
Christian schools then it's possible
that this thing that happened in DC
wouldn't have gotten as much attention
or wouldn't have gotten any attention
and obviously if you know if you change
the demographics around and it doesn't
feature white males then it would have
gotten no attention whatsoever but it
just so happens that it fits so
perfectly with what they were talking
about at least if you take it out of
context and you lie about certain
elements of the story certain crucial
elements then it fits so well so that's
why they took it and they fit it in so
it's not that this would that Nathan
Phillips was conspiring with you know
George Soros or something and they and
you know this was all this way it's more
this is just something that happened and
the left and the media knew what to do
with it they took it and they fit it
into what they were already talking
about but there's always a point okay
with with these narratives and these
themes when they hammer on them and the
left has not gone through the trouble of
paint and Christian schools as dangerous
hate factories for no reason they intend
to do something with it okay they're
going to they're going to use the fruits
of their labor to some end and that end
I think will become very clear very soon
okay now before we get to emails I want
to mention this from ABC News the
University of Notre Dame will cover
murals in a campus building that depicts
Christopher Columbus in America the
school's president said following
criticism that the images depict Native
Americans and stereotypical submissive
poses before white European explorers
the 12 murals were created in the 1880s
by Louise Grigory and they were intended
to encourage immigrants who had come to
the US during a period of anti-catholic
sentiment but they concealed another
side of Columbus the exploitation or
repression of Native Americans according
to the Reverend John Jenkins president
of the Notre Dame so they're going to
cover up these now here's what's going
to be and I just want to mention this
because this is just so emblematic of
the way that cowardly Christians deal
with things these days so what he's
doing is
he's not getting rid of the murals which
again this is this is art made in the in
the 19th century for for Notre Dame
given to them and so he's not gonna just
throw him white instead he's gonna cover
the murals and he indicated that
sometimes maybe for he would uncover
them on certain occasions and then
eventually they'll find somewhere else
on the campus to put the mural so
they're not getting rid of them it'll
put him somewhere else so what he's done
here and this is this is just what
cowardly Christians always do he's come
up with a compromise that actually
satisfies no one so he's caving to
pressure from from the left from society
from the world he's caving to the
pressure but he's not even doing what
they want so they're still gonna be mad
at him and then meanwhile those who
don't want him to cave are also gonna be
mad so he's just upset everyone and
accomplished nothing
this is what happens when you start
trying to compromise and you give up on
your principles and you start caving and
surrendering and everything it's you're
not even gonna satisfy the people who
are coming after the people who you are
bowing before and saying oh yes yes
please please Oh Matt dear master master
the people that you're doing that to
they're not going to be happy so you
just end up you end up with it's a
lose-lose meanwhile this I'm not gonna
get off on another tangent about
Christopher Columbus but as someone
who's actually read about him and
studied Columbus I still find him to be
one of the great one of the great men of
Western civilization obviously one of
the pioneers and initial builders of
Western civilization not a perfect man a
complex man and men who did great things
at any point in history but especially
back back in those days the great men
who did great things in accomplish great
they were always complex they always had
sides to them that were
less shall we say savoury and part of
that is because if if you if you wanted
to get on a ship with a bunch of other
guys and sail across uncharted waters
and go to this unknown wilderness and
try to build a civilization from scratch
which is something that none of us we
can't even conceive of that none of none
of us have ever done that what ever
seeing that happen we can't even wrap
our minds around what that even entails
to get on a ship with a bunch of
supplies and then say you don't we're
gonna just sail and hope that we find
land and we're gonna build civilization
about that none of us can even I mean
all the people that sit there and say
well he shouldn't have done it that way
well he shouldn't have done that that
part right there that was no good
meanwhile none of it we can't even find
our local Rite Aid without it without a
GPS and we're sitting here criticizing
but in order to do that you had to have
certain characteristics and you also had
to be a very harsh and severe sort of
man and and and also brutal it was kind
of necessary now that doesn't excuse the
bad things that Columbus did or the bad
things that anyone did throughout
history but it does put it within a
certain context that if you want to be
an intelligent person and you want to
study history and you want to have a
mature perspective on history and not a
childish one then you have to understand
the context but one way or another
Christopher Columbus the early explorers
discoverers pioneers settlers these are
the people who built the civilization
that you and I now live in and we are
enjoying the fruits of their labor
we are feasting on the banquet that they
provided us and even as we do that like
brats we sit and we whine about them and
complain and insult them well you know I
know it's a cliche to say if you don't
like it get out of America but sometimes
I think that response is wholly
appropriate and I think it goes I think
it applies
unless you're a hypocrite or an
intellectual coward if you really think
that that our civilization is built
fundamentally on genocide and evil and
slavery and all these things that's
really what you think and you think we
have no right to even be here and we
stole all this land and we're thieves
and criminals and everything then you
should leave for you to think that and
yet stay here and benefit from the
privileges that those genocide Oh
maniacs gave you that makes you just
incomprehensible cowardly if you really
feel that way then you must leave and go
live somewhere else I really mean that
you have to you can't possibly stay here
while thinking that it would be like if
if you're if your friend invited you
over for a house party and then you you
you come into the house you say wow this
is a really nice house a great party and
he's giving you a visa and then you find
out you say see when did you buy this
house and your friend says to you oh you
know no there was another family living
here and actually I just I just came in
and killed all of them and they're
buried out back but anyway the fruit
punches in the kitchen now if your
friend said that you you would leave the
house right you wouldn't just say oh
okay well you know what I disapproved
but let me go get some of that fruit
punch you wouldn't do that you would
leave the house and then you would call
the police right now I don't think that
that analogy is at all similar to what
the early settlers and explorers did but
the point is liberals that is how they
think of it they think it's exactly like
that yet they're staying in the house
party cowards
okay now to the inbox if you want to
send a message to the show ask a
question offer a comment compliment me
insult me or anything else you can
e-mail Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com Matt well show
gmail.com you could also get ahold of me
through Facebook and Twitter and a
million other means but I'm trying to
consolidate things here so as best I can
from Andy he says
look well also Justin writes your your
number two next to Ben in my daily
subscription sometimes a better show
than his even I hope he's paying you
well watch out Michael Knowles Thank You
Justin my my great goal in life is to be
second place so I appreciate that no I
do appreciate it thank you from Logan
what does the Left have correct that the
right is failing to understand that is a
great great question what does the left
have correct that the right is failing
to understand I like that question I
think there's a big one I've talked
about this before they understand I
think what what sorts of issues will
fire people up and motivate people they
know how to get to people's hearts and
to win hearts and they know that you
need to win the heart first and then the
mind it's heart than mind right which as
I pointed out it's something that
conservatives tend to not understand
so conservatives will go on and on about
things like tax policy and jobs and so
on which are important obviously but
you're not going to build movements
around them
at least not these days you won't even
something like immigration okay really
important issue an issue that lots of
people care about obviously and for a
good reason
but I'll tell you this if you had a
march on Washington for or against
illegal immigration you're not gonna get
even a fraction of what the March for
Life gets every single year
okay the March for Life pulls three four
hundred five hundred thousand people
you're not gonna get those those kinds
of numbers for an immigration march you
just walked I mean you might get a
thousand ten thousand maybe if you
promote it really well because abortion
you know the social issues the cultural
issues these are the issues that have
that are that speak to people at the
most intrinsic kind of level and they
have a very deep philosophical dimension
to them because they get down to the
meaning and purpose of life and of
society and of human existence and so
those are those are the questions that
we all think
about those are the things we care about
those are the things that we order our
lives around right you know there are
many Pro lifers who have who have
ordered their life around their
conviction that life is sacred and
valuable and that abortion is horrible
it needs to be outlawed there are not as
many people who have centered their life
around immigration although there are
some who specialized in that issue but
not nearly as many because these are the
most fundamental most important most
central kinds of issues and this is
where our primary focus should be
liberals understand that and that's why
they've been so effective in in you know
claiming the culture for themselves
notice by the way how long it took just
as an example notice how long it took
conservatives to figure out that this
gender stuff transgenderism and all that
notice how long it took them to figure
out that this was something they needed
to pay attention to I remember when I
was writing my my book the unholy
trinity which you can find in bookstores
today or on Amazon and I talked a lot
about transgenderism in that in that
book and I remember I was pitching that
to the publisher and the publisher told
me when I was originally talking about
the book with them they said they said
well yeah but the transgenderism they
are people really gonna care about that
by the time the book comes out and I
said yeah they're gonna care about care
about it this is this is a this is an
issue now this is a thing people care
about and it just took conservative long
time to figure that out Aaron writes
Matt I agree with you about the
Covington Catholic situation but here's
my thing the response from church
leadership has been terrible my own
diocese denounce the boys as soon as it
happened I've seen many priests and
bishops on social media denouncing them
too this seems like total cowardice to
me what do you think I think you said it
well Aaron and I totally agree with you
Joe says I don't understand what you're
about or why anyone cares what you think
why did the Daily wire feel the need to
hire an apocalyptic preacher you're like
a hipster John the Baptist and I don't
mean that as a compliment I only want to
hear about Ben Shapiro I don't care
about you well Joe you don't mean that
as a compliment but I actually take it
as one
hipster John the Baptist I you know I
don't think I'm a hipster but I love I
think I might have to put that on my
Twitter bio from William he says Matt
have you heard of the economic school of
thought known as distributism Thomas e
woods jr. of the Mises Institute
describes distributists as believing
that social system is best in which
productive property is widely dispersed
rather than concentrated G K Chesterton
perhaps the most well known and
respected advocate of distributism
famously said too much capitalism does
not mean too many capitalists but too
few proponents of the Austrian Chicago
School of Economics usually criticize
distributors of trying to sneak in
socialism to the back door because of
their insistence that as many workers as
possible ought to own the means of their
own labor thus and then he asks what do
you make of distributism thanks for that
William I I'm a little familiar with
distributism
I love Chesterton and so anything he
says I think should be taken seriously I
think the comparison to socialism is
off-base because the point of
distributism is precisely to make sure
that everyone owns property a private
property is the point private ownership
and that is not communal ownership an
actual private owner as in actual
individuals owning their own land in
their own means of production now I
think of this as less of an economic
system as more and more of sort of a
philosophical more of a philosophy
Chesterton's point i think is that the
the best thing the most moral the most
human thing is for everyone to own
something to own land own means of
production not own as a community not
own as a state or through the state but
actually owned for themselves privately
and I think Chesterton was horrified by
a world where so few people actually
owned anything and he thought well
that's just that's not human humans
should own things the profit and I agree
with that the problem of course is that
there's no way to get to there with
everybody owning their own chunk of land
and their own means of production
there's no way to get there from where
we are without the government
confiscating everything and then and
then kind of redistributing it as they
see fit which which obviously would be
saying and terrible in cataclysmic and
tyrannical and awful so there's no way
anyone could support that and there's no
way it would ever happen but look here's
what I'll say about the Shimon if and I
think that this is not a far-fetched
Nereo if the whole world comes crumbling
down and there's some sort of
apocalyptic event and civilization is is
reduced to ash and then a few survivors
are left and we're looking at rebuilding
society rebuilding civilization and we
all get together and we say what sort of
economic system should we start with I
think then starting from scratch maybe
you could look at the [ __ ] Buddhism as a
model Tyson says hey man I'll keep this
short at school my history teacher is
very left-leaning and we've been
discussing illegal illegal immigration I
am in full support of the wall and tried
to minimize these people from coming
into our country every time the topic
comes up his argument or deflection when
I state my opinion as always well did
your family come here legally and I
honestly do not know the answer to that
question I am wondering what a good
response to come by the question is
instead of leaving me stuck Tyson the
first answer is that it's irrelevant
even if you're even if your family did
come here illegally which I mean I
assume you know if they did or didn't
but whether they did it that's got
nothing to do with the issue the issue
is whether or not we should protect the
border whether or not we should have
immigration laws so when someone says
well what about you what did you do what
do what about your family
it okay that that can that can speak to
your own personal credibility or
whatever maybe but it has nothing to do
with the issue so even if somebody could
could prove that you're a hypocrite that
doesn't mean that you're wrong about
what you say so that's a way that is a
way of deflecting it's a way of not
engaging with the organ so the first
thing I would say when your teacher says
that is okay you know I don't know about
my family but can we stick to the issue
can you stop deflecting from the issue
let's talk about the issue and and
secondly this idea that that we're all
you know ancestors of illegal immigrants
is of course ridiculous and false and
you know there are you know my family
came here I don't know
many years ago they came here legally so
the claim just doesn't make any sense to
begin with
Allison rights Matt I go to CPAC every
year and I always expect you to be there
but you never are will you be there this
year will you be speaking well Allison
I'd love to be at CPAC but I've never
been invited sniff here but I mean if
you really wanted me to speak at CPAC
which again I'd love to do you could
always reach out to CPAC on Twitter and
say hey invite Matt Walsh or something I
don't know I mean it's something you
could do it really wanted to finally max
says Matt your comment that LeBron James
is the best basketball player of all
time was insane have you ever heard of
Michael Jordan never lost a Finals end
of discussion
well that's not the other discussion
Michael Jordan was in the league for I
think 16 years he only went to the final
six times that means that he missed the
finals 10 times my LeBron James has been
in the league I think also for 16 years
and if you don't he's on his 16th year I
believe he's been to the finals nine
times already so um this idea that were
giving Jordan credit for losing before
the finals oh he's undefeated the file
he missed it 10 times he lost you know
why he was undefeated because he lost
before he got to the finals ten times
how is that bet how is it more clutch to
lose before the finals than to lose in
the finals that doesn't make any sense
and of course when you're doing with a
Finals record thing you're not factoring
in number one in 2007 LeBron James went
to the finals and he dragged a team that
without him would not even have sniffed
the playoffs and he dragged them on his
own to the finals the fact that he lost
there is irrelevant
just making it is one of the most
impressive feats in in modern sports
history and then also LeBron James has
three times played the best team in the
history of the game Jordan never played
a team like the Warriors never he never
played a team that having the Warriors
have three of the best scorers in the
league on the same team and Jordan never
played a team quite like that so I still
say that LeBron James the best
basketball player of all time thanks for
watching everybody will will leave it
there thanks for listening talk to you
tomorrow goodbye and Godspeed